but it's not a movie you can discuss
casually and that's what we're learning
like this is this is like you're the
only one i've talked this deep about it
i think one thing we can promise is
there's going to be no other review like
this
i don't think i've ever done a review
like this
because it's like we're both like it's
good these are our opposing viewpoints
yeah and what's interesting is we both
enjoy the film objectively whereas i
think it was an emotional journey and
you think it was an intellectual journey
but i think my intellectual processing
of it was just different than yours yes
i might slap that on to the beginning of
the video to set the theme for all of
you there's nothing wrong with that yeah
that's my fault your life experience at
you because i'd still definitely
recommend the movie i think i just
realized exactly
the the core thing
that is missing for me we did it you
guys
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation we
are going to talk about eternals all you
saw before was pretty much uh like what
what i would say in a long social media
twitter thread you know bullet points of
things sometimes people watch those and
they think that's a full review and it's
not so i got coijandro with me today
what's your like quick 30 seconds to 60
second opinion of the entire film yeah
uh 30 60 seconds would you say twitter
would say that eternals is not only
unique to itself it's unique to the
sci-fi genre beyond the superhero genre
in that it approaches subject matter in
a way that could only exist in the film
that it is so it's dense it's
complicated it's all encompassing but
that movie couldn't exist to its scope
and scale without the mcu films that led
before it so it's a trusting endearing
bold choice of filmmaking that should be
an independent film with a 200 million
dollar budget that exceeds at all the
things it's set out to do so in other
words koi hated it hated it yeah he
didn't he quite hated
so after i put out my quick thoughts on
the movie what i love is that you know
when you put out quick thoughts on the
internet i think a big part of
communication is listening it's like how
they say an acting a big part of acting
is reacting uh my favorite form of
communication is mind reading and
assuming i think you guys nailed it i
absolutely said that it's not a typical
mcu film so i hated it i said i didn't
like it i remember saying those words
that i don't like it yup i i remember
saying there's not enough mindless
action in here i remember saying i don't
get it was it dense because i think
i might have been uh the only one to
have said those words no what i want to
do is uh like in the words of vision i
request elaboration on myself here
yes so what i want to do really quick
and uh you know koi he'll he'll he'll
overpower this whole conversation in
just a couple minutes
but i would like to elaborate on a
couple of things first so with the movie
eternals this basically has two plot
lines you're following i would say a
third of the movie and it's set up from
the get-go and they've already
established online that there you are
gonna be in the past a lot so one third
of the movie you keep cutting back to is
the eternals they're them coming into
existence why they're here on earth and
you're watching how they like took on
the deviants through thousands of years
of history and how they helped humanity
in the shadows and then the other two
thirds basically sets them up that they
haven't been together in thousands of
years the deviants are back so it's
about getting the band back together
right that's a probably their most
efficient way to explain the plot of the
movie
there we are yeah yeah so eternals are
these like wonderful beings that were
created by celestials and so i think
like one thing that i really appreciate
this movie for b i think when i said
that it's dense and i'm still processing
it that communicated to a lot of people
that i'm i'm still trying to understand
the movie but i'm like no that's not
really what i'm processing what i'm
processing is to see how i emotionally
feel towards this movie did i really
like it and i honestly didn't know at
the time that's why i was like i guess
it's okay
in fairness to greg i tweeted out a
sentence or two and said i'd be back in
the morning for my first thoughts so i
took a knight he did not yeah i think
it's it's not fair to say like person
dumb waited think it's literally a
matter of processing rendering because
as much as the common term for this
movie is dense it's not as dense as dune
it's not as dense as the matrix it's
dense sure i really love thematically
everything they're dealing with because
there's so many different themes that
you are handling in this one movie
pretty much handling genesis all over
again and i love movies that not only do
sci-fi fantasy but also manage to mix it
in with religion simultaneously i do
feel like it's not actually a difficult
movie to follow i don't think it's a
hard move it's not like watching tenet
the movie actually does one thing that i
think it does better than a lot of mcu
movies is it breathes it takes its time
it really allows you to sit with things
and i really appreciate that and i think
all the things they are exploring are
very awesome in this movie dealing with
humanity creation rebirth love you know
they got a whole and there's more in
there than even just that the thing
though for me and i i felt like i was i
i articulated it but apparently not i
was saying i don't really know if i felt
much while watching it i thought it was
a great observation piece at the time
and it didn't quite hit me until the
next day of why i felt that way here's
what i'll say though too before i go
into it i'm not the kind of individual
you guys might have seen with a few
movies here not a lot a few i've changed
my mind on some movies over time when
having a different perspective on it i'm
not the kind of individual who's married
to his own feelings or opinion i know
what they are currently about this movie
and i don't take back anything i said in
my instant reaction i also want to watch
it again and i presented something to
you that you said like affected your
overall take there was a negative
criticism i had towards druid that is
the only thing i really talked with koi
about yeah beforehand my boy i talked
with uh i talked about druid and he said
something there and a couple minutes
later i was like actually no that does
enhance my perspective on it here's why
i think i wasn't emotionally drawn to it
and so i'm very curious to know for
someone like you who said who cried a
couple times while watching this and
those two-thirds of the plot that they
are going through there are a lot of
conversations that they're having like a
lot of it is mainly just the eternals
getting the band back together and a lot
of conversing not really a lot of action
it's mainly a lot of conversations
exploring the themes of what i was just
talking about what i noticed the next
day was okay i get their goals you know
how they say every character needs a
goal you gotta save earth spoilers yeah
right they gotta save earth and then the
plot gets crazier uh you know they have
that thing in the mcu where it's like
there's an actual bigger reveal ahead
than just deviants are back because for
me when they're showing the one-third of
the story whenever they're encountering
deviants they're whipping ass like it's
no problem right it's like not a problem
for them when the main catalyst for the
present day plot was deviants are back
i'm like do i really need to worry about
this
and it's a while before they introduce
another layer to make the threat
actually more menacing i think what gets
me personally emotionally attached to
characters and their journeys and their
goals is
really getting to feel why they have
that goal
wise angles not just gold take like two
different characters tony stark it's
pretty he wants to save to help save the
earth and we know why in that movie yeah
you see the experiences you feel the
experiences he goes through so you know
why or even take a villain like the
mandarin and uh shanghi
you know his goal and the movie really
lets you sit with why and show you why
and i thought with this they do so much
conversing just amongst themselves and
and it's kind of a debate of like should
we save humanity should we not save
humanity and it was a lot of telling and
i never got invested in
why they should save humanity or wha or
why they have these goals some people
are telling me that sure it's dealing
with the relationships of the eternals
and i never even really got the sense
from them that they're longing for
family connection with each other when a
lot of people have told me that that's a
big part of the movie is them coming
together and you really feel like
they're a family my point being is that
i get all their goals on paper
i just as characters and a storytelling
journey i thought everything around it
was much more interesting i think that
everyone's really distinct and uh you
get time with every one of them yep i
really appreciate that and i appreciate
everything they're talking about i just
felt like it was more coming from here
and not much from here and for me that's
a big factor for me enjoying a movie
funny enough it's like the tone and the
mood and the atmosphere wasn't enough to
make me fall in love with it and the way
how like dune sort of got me
can i counter i don't want you to like
argue me
but my perspective ties directly into
that so i wanted this yeah
one of the things that you just had as
an issue is one of the things that i
thought was a strength so that's why i
wanted to integrate cool
so what i loved about this being an
ensemble is that there isn't a single
character that feels like is getting all
of the light all of the attention all of
the focus all of the anything and that
had been a concern for me with certain
people being cast i was worried angelina
jolie it would be an angelina jolie film
in the marvel universe just like
sometimes you watch a movie and even
when it's an ensemble you're like but
that person's a movie star and they tend
to be like oh whole cast but look over
here at no point did i feel like this
was angelina jolie and friends when in a
lot of cases i feel like it's like
wolverine and the x-men like no it's the
x-men so i really appreciated the fact
that it was such an ensemble that the
conflict all came from those discussions
to the point where i loved that i knew
all of their arcs and i knew all of
their goals so much here and here for me
that when there was any discrepancy in
one of their opinions and when you saw
emotionally them struggling with a
family member disagreeing with them you
didn't need it to be more than a
conversation because i felt hurt and i
felt affected because i knew this
character so well and i knew this
character so well i trusted their arc so
well that i knew inevitably in the next
few minutes this would happen and since
i cared about them so much this was
enough for me in dialogue much like loki
where you have these great conversations
with mobius and loki that are these
insane existential ponderings these
beautiful introspective looks at the
broadest concepts of man that when these
are in a perspective about man instead
of from man i'm invested as a man and
i'm saying that as a person i don't want
internet to be like
women too mankind i think it's really
beautiful as a human being to hear these
concepts as an abstract i think it's
really beautiful as a human being that
is fascinated by theology that is
fascinated by mortality and morality to
have characters that are removed from
that in their own way discussing it
about me like i'm not in the room so
what i got out of that where you might
not have connected in the way that you
did was i liked feeling removed because
i am see that's the thing is the main
thing i told koi before we filmed was i
don't
disagree with pretty much everyone
who likes this movie i think like what
they're doing is technically it's all
there that's why it's hard for me to
kind of articulate my point here take
what you're saying it's all there and i
think a big part of it is like you know
they've been in the shadows they're
larger than life and they were there to
observe and help out but not be directly
involved that's the part of it though
that i'm like they they talk so much
about humanity but i never really got
the sense of their relationship with
humanity so some people might say
they've been in the shadows and the
whole point is for them to be detached
but i'm like but wait a minute there's a
middle plot here
of they've been here pretty much not
with each other a lot of them have been
living amongst humans for
thousands of years and i never got a
sense of how has their relationship
changed with humans what how has
humanity affected
them emotionally and like there's a
couple characters where i i know that
all the ants are very obvious that's
what i mean by why so for me the
conflict is the inherent why for me them
having these feelings shows the stuff
that we don't see for me them feeling
like i can't do this because of this i
don't need to see the a and the b
because i got the c you can't really
have time for everyone's a and b if
they're feeling this there's an
emotional journey that landed them at
that place yes yeah i know what you're
saying because ajax there's this moment
where she is talking about
ajax or ajax hey jack okay
there's a moment where ajax has this
monologue talking about like i've seen
humanity for you know but with salma
hayek with a much better accent and
bigger boobs as she likes to proclaim
and it's true ajax is having this this
speech about like i've seen humanity um
you know how like all the terrible
things they've done but i've also seen
like the loving good things they've done
and that's what i mean it's like they
they talk about some stuff
they talk with any of them you could cut
like you get that more with fastos
that's a big part of why i love fast oh
man well he's the one you get to
experience the humanity mode yes that he
is the marvel's first like superhero gay
character and he has like a husband in
this husband or boyfriend i forget in
the present day timeline that's the part
of like here's how relationally he has
changed yeah i'm saying everyone needs
to have a family or whatever i'm saying
this is a evident part of why relation
has changed kingo i think a lot of
people more than the fact that it's
funny enough with kingo he's one of the
most like talked about characters coming
out of this movie and out of any eternal
he's probably the most mcu familiar oh
yeah you know like he pretty much got
camille nanjiani to not a hundred
percent play camille nanjiani but he's
pretty much doing his kim male 19 things
with the comedy he's funny narcissistic
like he's the most like mcu familiar
type of them all but he at least even
gets a scene where he shows concern
for people in a present day thing
totally removed from god you don't see
them talking but i think they all do
so each and ever i can right now in each
and every character think of a moment
that they show why they're invested in
humanity but i can't think of how to do
that without spoiling the moments
because i don't want people to be one i
don't want you to be like i'm waiting
for this person's moment with this nor
do i want to reveal it so they have any
moments to look forward to so that's
what i'm saying with the spoiler review
pin this moment and put a link right
here future greg connecting to when i
break down all of the leeds connection
with humanity when the spoiler view
happens because i can and it's beautiful
that they took the time in my opinion to
give us this is why they care this is
how it connects this is how it conflicts
this is how it ends this could be eight
movies cs thing i just don't feel for
the y on it i think the y is kind of
touched on
briefly but i don't feel like they
needed to go into into more than that
because the it's a web if if it was a
movie about this character or this
character then you'd follow their arc
but instead it's a movie about these
characters so all the conflict comes
from the web the center so you're not
supposed to feel each individual
person's connection because that would
be a different movie what you're
supposed to feel is the eternals
connection as why the conflict which
hasn't been revealed is in fact a
problem because they do a beautiful
thing in this film where they in the
trailer describe
why they didn't do anything at x y z
that's the trailer they reveal why
because uh uh homeboy jon snow asks why
you didn't interrupt this ex blah blah
that's act one of a series of things
about eternals that wouldn't work if
each of them had a streamlined
connection it's the conflict around
that's revealed
that matters
yeah i don't think you're wrong
is going to be you saying you agree with
me and going but i still feel
emotionally boring but i said me being
like i cried twice i just couldn't i
just didn't ever feel for the goal
what's interesting is we both enjoy the
film objectively whereas i think it was
an emotional journey and you think it
was an intellectual journey but i think
my intellectual processing of it was
just different than yours yes
i might slap that on to the beginning of
the video to set the theme for all of
them there's nothing wrong with that
yeah that's my fault your life
experience at you because i'd still
definitely recommend the movie 100 like
and then stop because of like yeah i
didn't like it but i still recommend it
i'm like no it's it's a good movie that
was just something i found myself
craving was i needed it i needed to get
a better sense of it in order to care
about the journey they're going on
that's why a lot of bond movies are kind
of bland to me right so you don't care
about cause i'm like yeah i get it save
the world and that's better yeah
like that's why it can be boring for me
there were three characters that i was
so invested in that i'd watch them lead
their own movie because their arc was so
emotionally connected to me actually
four
so four connectors i would be like
giving a spin off of blank yeah right
now but that was based on emotion and
the intellectual headiness of the
character choice whereas like it sounds
like you liked the movie but that might
have been the case for you and that's
going to be a lot of other people's
experience you know what i just realized
why the conversations don't click for me
as well
is you just made the comparison to loki
which by the way is like wanda vision
and loki are my favorite things to come
out of phase four so far i love the idea
of conversation i guess the movie kind
of lacked a pulse for me okay and a and
a good ticking clock and i feel like
that's all you kind of need sometimes
because the clock the ticking clock of
the movie is introduced kind of late
it's like kind of like in the in the
middle of just so funny because that's
what i loved about it the thing that i
liked was that this doesn't have a
three-act structure in a traditional
sense because the thing that causes the
ticking clock yes doesn't get revealed
until way after you're invested but by
the time i got to the ticking clock i
realized i don't really think i care as
much about the goals as i like this is
so interesting the whole point is when
you get to the ticking clock moment yeah
that's when the goals become like oh
this is a real threat and that we really
need to now we need to really have this
conversation i think i like the uh
conversations i like what they're doing
what
hooks me emotionally into conversations
is a strong debate though i think this
is where i'm gonna differ with so many
people on the opinion about the debates
that are written here because i didn't
really feel like they were strongly
written debates i thought they were more
interesting conversations take like the
great debate in jurassic park of should
we or sh that's pretty much what they're
doing here but what the world you
thought so much of uh can we never
thought should we or what however that
how's that folk go do you know what i'm
talking about you know you know
yeah yeah
that's the point of the conversation i
found myself just kind of craving
something more from them like a little
bit of an intensity or a little bit more
of a pulse to the debates versus
interesting conversations like you're
kind of watching a greek god play or
something the first bit up until the
ticking clock is dazed and confused and
it's
existing while observing and i loved
that about it and i think that might be
a big split with us is the thing i liked
was that i felt like i got to experience
what these conversations would be like
if it wasn't in a movie i got to
experience like what would eternals talk
about and what would they be pondering
without that clock and once the clock
came i was like oh that ups the stakes
that's cool but like i didn't it was
like a great escalation of movie that i
was already in i was already invested
that's so invested that's fair
no i mean that's fair
i'm so intrigued
because it's almost a one-to-one
difference of how we felt about the
things that i loved and you didn't while
still both going objectively good movies
so i feel like i would have i would have
enjoyed this more as a read
more than a movie i don't think i would
have gotten through it as a read because
i was so emotionally invested by the
characters acting choices to get me
invested i think one thing we can
promise is there's gonna be no other
review like this
i don't think i've ever done a review
like this
it's like we're both like it's good
these are our opposing viewpoints this
has been mental gymnastics not to spoil
anything because all of my points are
tied specifically to moments that i
loved getting to experience without
knowing much about it the trailer's done
an awesome job of saying like why you
should go see it without revealing much
of the plot and it does a great thing
where it surprises you in its marvel way
like you referred to but in a way more
existential what would you do concept in
that you've already invested in so many
characters that you might attach to a
different character than me or to greg
or to uh you know the person you're
watching it with where i very
specifically attached to two characters
and kind of two more but they all had
different viewpoints to the point where
i was like how do i feel about this
question okay see i think that's maybe
just my my personal problem with is i i
never found myself fully attached to
anyone i was kind of just like
so that's how we experience the movie
differently i was so attached to
multiple people that when they would
have a conversation which you didn't
feel as attached to i was like which
side am i on and that's what made the
movie sing for me oh yeah i didn't have
oh i had it
i had that so immediately that's that's
so funny
i love being thrusted into that position
i do i crave that it was amazing like
that's the thing is i could see what the
movie's going for at all times i got
four mobiuses i don't actually agree
with the sentiment that there's gonna be
a big divide with this movie i think i
honestly i think the rotten tomatoes
score is going to be on the lower side
of marvel if not lowest um i don't know
i think i think maybe audience-wise
that's what i'm talking about critics is
going to be in the middle eyes audience
is going to be in the last i don't think
it's going to be rotten though
but i'm talking about like i think uh i
would say it's not going to be like
shanghi numbers i get that critics are
going to be in i would say the 80s but i
think that audience is going to be in
like the 50s and it's not going to be
because of anyone's lack well to be some
people lack of intelligence because
statistically some people are dumb yeah
but in in the grand scheme of things it
won't resonate with some people like
this conversation why do you think
there'll be a divide i personally think
it'll be a divide because people are
gonna check out early if it's not the
tone they're expecting i think people
are not used to things paced this way i
think this movie is a two million dollar
movie with a 200 million dollar budget
in that it tells a two million dollar
style story they make art house films
with these concepts they make smaller
films with these things that are so
timely slowly paced uh conversational
they don't make 200 million dollar
movies like this the dichotomy between
the mental experience and the emotional
resonance is going to be much wider than
any other film like it there's nothing
quite like a 200 million dollar art film
they don't do this so i think people i
don't think it's that artsy
it's very art
this whole movie takes place at sunset
greg i think it's disguised as an artsy
the whole movie takes place at sunset
it's all a golden hour shot that's the
definition of artsy there are more
handholding shots than action shots and
that's what i loved about it okay this
is probably where i'm going to disagree
with a lot of people then i feel like it
wants to be as more artsy than it
actually is i think it wants to be more
of an mcu film than it actually is see
that's where but you see how we have
these budding of odds yeah that's what i
mean i felt that kind of thing
they wanted to go you had a comparison
during our dune discussion certain types
of sci-fi genres yeah to me it wanted to
be more star trek
but was kind of being pushed to be more
star wars and i felt like it was more
the town and it sometimes went in the
departed
so you know because
no matter what i say it sounds like
what's wrong with that crack
i'm using that to support the reason of
like i don't think it's as like slow and
heady as some people are making it out
to be to the point whereas i'm like
there's plenty of there's still plenty
of action in this movie i found myself
less interested in the action i actually
thought the third act was when i was
least invested you see the third act
kind of reminded me of power rangers
there's a shot when the costumes are
fully like you know you've seen that
you've seen the costumes and there's a
moment where the lighting shifts and i
was definitely like that's not the same
movie in an emotionally resonant way and
that's when i was like oh i know why
this is going this direction but i like
the conversations more let's look at uh
cersei and icarus's relationship yeah
that is a big part of this movie that is
a huge part of this movie is that in the
past they were lovers and then in the
present they're not but they're
regrouped up right i could not feel
anything for their relationship i know
we feel very different
i know
i know we do
like there was so much dedicated to them
being in love falling in love and then
it's very obvious that icarus still
brings this girl i kind of got it in the
past like i get it they're like stoic
godlike characters you know when you're
doing a love story and i don't feel for
them being i think in order to feel
the compelling weight of potential
heartbreak around the corner
right without spoiling anything like in
order to feel the weight of that or the
tragedy of this this what could have
been a beautiful relationship between
these two but certain things divide them
i need to care about them being in love
first and i did not ever care for their
love story take blue valentine movies
amazing it's amazing why because it's
not just people bitching at each other
the whole time because when they do such
a good job at cutting to them when they
were falling in love
you forget about all that other crap
that's consistent and i and i was like i
think when they're in love they're
really boring that would have been a not
good two-person movie and that's the
strength of this being like an
eight-person movie that i'm speaking of
the web of because those are two of my
four and i was invested in them in the
broader sense i cared about their
relationship but i cared more about how
that relationship affected the
conversation we can't talk about
see the thing though is is like
my one counter to that is i find it odd
that so much time is committed to that
yet i was
way more invested
in the specific relationship that has
been revealed in magazines prior to this
movie coming out about gilgamesh
and athena
their relationship
i cared so much more about that and
nowhere near as much screen time is
devoted to them i care way more about
the scenes where they paired up druid
and makari way more than i do care about
the thing they're really putting a lot
of attention to but i think that was
intentional john had the issue with dune
with timmy chalamet right yeah he's
wrong
and we can acknowledge that
but like with chalamet being he felt
like having uh not quite the same amount
of gravitas in those moments i think you
need to have your leads not steal
attention away from the people with less
screen time i was invested in the
relationship but i didn't need it to be
the weight of the other ones in the
speed that it was because they had less
time to show it i think you know what if
you're going to put more time to it it
should hold it just as equal of weight i
i think i think it did equal weight okay
yeah for me it didn't okay
that's very much
yeah okay yeah i was more invested in
the the web than anyone's relationship
two one two no what i was getting at
though was i don't think it needs to
just be a two-person movie the way
because i don't want to say blue
valentine like yeah the whole movie
the whole movie's devoted to those two
i'm saying i think there's definitely
ways with the same amount of screen time
where they could have made that way more
interesting and uh to watch as i because
this is the thing is like i talked to a
lot of people who i've seen talk about
this movie publicly and they are totally
shying away from a lot of things because
they're obviously afraid of the internet
it sucks when people hate you for your
opinion all right and it feels great
we're real people i know this is an area
of the movie that is not problematic but
um difficulty getting attached because a
big part of caring about the journey
emotionally caring feeling kind of
disconnected from the love relationship
that they keep putting in front and
center
or or the the dichotomy between these
two but yeah i mean you liked it though
i did you cared about it yeah so yeah
and i just did it
yeah so i think that's been the thing is
like we can both see the movie as
working but for different reasons and
the emotional resonance only worked for
me in certain scenes you for certain
scenes and and that's going to be how
people experience life up until the
moment they sat in that seat that's the
thing about art is it's so
a receiver now you can make whatever you
want it's how people receive it that's
why it's beautiful that movies are so
varied but for me this movie
accomplished something i didn't think
was possible in this in this space i
didn't think you could have this many
characters feel like an ensemble where
it didn't feel like there were opposing
viewpoints that didn't work all the
opposing viewpoints did work and i love
that it's a movie that deals with such
concepts that is so conversational but
still is in the superhero space like
it's very much a film that affects
everything but it also is something that
if you've never seen an mcu film you
will get a lot out of
true
yeah
perhaps
i think someone that's never seen an mcu
film can walk into this and love it sure
sure yeah and that's not you can't say
that for most superhero films yeah
that's fair and it's also a movie that
if you're a devout superhero fan you
might not love and i love that this is
how you keep the bubble from bursting
this is how you make films and movies
like we've everyone and their mother
since phase one has been like guardians
there's a high school man
yeah but this is something else and knew
entirely in my opinion i guess i just
didn't find it like uh as
thought-provoking like i've been
thinking about it non-stop sense that's
so fascinating to me because i love
thought-provoking sci-fi fantasy those
are my favorite kind of movies but if
you didn't connect emotionally
thought-provoking won't work yeah i'm
just more like interesting and i feel
like i've heard this conversation done
better and i feel like i didn't ever
have i felt like i'd never seen
something to this scale with the sure
this been going on since people to me it
was apparently i could think of other
movies that did similar conversations
but better and but what's supposed to
make it unique and interesting is that
you're watching it from like these these
godlike characters talk about it that's
that's the part of it that's supposed to
make it more uh emotionally engaging and
to me this did more than the comics as
far as making that's cool like i
actually enjoy eternals the movie more
than most eternal comics and i don't get
that experience very often so that's the
thing that really elevated for me is i
was like oh oh that's what these comics
represent because there's been a lot of
times i was like reading out of
continuity just for the sake of reading
it in fact i think this was so good for
me it's going to retroactively improve a
lot of comics cool
i like that i like to hear that
like this movie's getting worse in your
eyes as we've talked you're like i just
feel nothing no no you make me
appreciate this movie a lot more i'm not
gonna i can't deny that i think with the
conversations what was going on would
why i wasn't finding the debate all that
interesting it would have been a much
more fascinating conversation for me
perhaps this is like just occurring to
me now it probably would have been a
much more fascinating debate
if it didn't feel like it leaned so
heavily on humanity is good and here's
why we need to save them and i thought
it could have been a much more
interesting conversation slash debate if
they really talked about
extensively as to or as devoted to why
humanity is also terrible i feel like
there were three or three of i feel like
there's three characters that have that
i think
no there are characters who have that
yeah i'm saying the actual converse it's
a lot of this is dialogue and them just
talking in in kind of barren locations a
lot of it seemed to really lean heavily
towards that that's what i mean by like
nah it's still a superhero movie like it
seemed to lean so heavily towards that
and i thought it would have been cooler
if they had a stronger conversation
it's hard it is hard to talk about right
because yeah i keep yeah i keep
navigating away from my own brain
their characters come to mind where
obviously i know what they think but i
think a lot of the screen time and
script writing devoted to conversing
about it was leaning heavily way more
towards the good of humanity i i think
so too but i think that's also like
the only way humanity survives in real
life like i think the only way we keep
existing is by assuming we're gonna
figure it out totally i just didn't find
it for a movie i thought it would have
been more interesting so maybe that's
another thing like my baseline is always
always always always always seeking an
excuse to keep tolerating people so as a
human i was a human person yeah as as me
this i wake up and i go like okay this
all sucks this all sucks this person's
monster i see this i read this youtube
comment people are awful and then i'm
consciously going okay find the good
find the good find the good find the
good and i felt that from this film and
i appreciated that because i'm i'm an
optimist by necessity otherwise i can't
keep operating because people have
proven time and time again that we are
devoid of most good but you find those
little [ __ ] magic nuggets of humanity
that are worth saving and i think this
accomplished that
i think it leans so much more into that
and it could and i thought it would have
been better balanced with having the
opposite side of it kind of like with
thanos point of view what's towards the
population you know me as an individual
of course i support and try to live my
life by that i think although there are
interesting conversations to be had with
knowing just how much humanity has
really messed up our world sure beyond
just
wars and violence we've we've really
just messed up the world too right and
they addressed that i thought they
address
but they don't dive into it man this
book under four hours spoiler view
because there's so much i want to say we
haven't just like before
you can discuss casually and that's what
we're learning like this is this is like
you're the only one i've talked this
deep about it
everyone else has been pretty surprised
really okay what are those conversations
like the surface conversation is
everything i agree with the music i
actually think is phenomenal i think
it's great they shot on location there
are some action scenes that are
riveting while others i don't feel are
as interesting but it's not really about
the action it's about the story and the
characters the celestials
everything realized them the scope and
scale beautiful to behold and you feel
the scopic nature of it like it is it is
so s like the enormity the seismic
quality of it more than just look how
big that is it
it really sucks you in it's kind of
scary that to me elicited the most
emotion when we like on just a visual
mood tone level cutting to the
celestials that was the thing that would
elicit the most emotion i mean like it's
actually kind of scary to behold right
and to get immersed into i think is
like they nailed that the acting's good
it's just some people walk out and tell
me that they like couldn't care less so
they care less about it or not and this
is why i don't talk to a lot but i don't
i don't but i think like so that's what
i mean from like a filmmaking standpoint
i'm like no everything's solid i don't
think there's anything weak about that
you know like i i did find myself
occasionally craving a more interesting
environment for them to have the
discussion but as we've talked about
this i do think that it doesn't really
come down to
really the location where they're
shooting it was more about my issue with
the feelings i had around the
conversation right less a location
sounds like the first act really is
going to make or break everyone's
experience of this i think you're going
to either need to fall in love with all
of these characters like i did or you're
going to have a conversation where you
can appreciate what's happening
intellectually but without the emotional
resonance feeling hollow and one of the
things i do want to address is and i
didn't know if i would because the
internet but here i am going to be brave
about it the internet uh i i love
how much we're getting to see people see
themselves on screen more and more i
love that we're leaving the age of
everyone has to look like the comic book
because these comics were written in the
60s uh when everyone's white uh and and
the the whites have always claimed this
[ __ ] and i think it's beautiful that
we're getting out of that into a world
where we can adjust there's a lot of
gender swapping here there's a lot of
playing with sexuality there's a lot of
seeing yourself on screen i have never
ever ever once looked at me had to
complain about not seeing myself on
screen so i didn't expect at all to have
a new level of emotional resonance
because i've had the avengers looking
pretty white for a long time but i gotta
say when druid was irish
so irish and felt like my world i'm
wicked irish when he felt like home i
got to understand what so many people
have been saying in a not just uh
intellectual way intellectually i've
been so excited for so many of my
friends to feel represented
intellectually i can go like that's
awesome i've never felt it and i think a
big part of what made me love this film
so much is druid being irish without
being a cliche without being a
leprechaun without being something that
felt like they were using him as a plot
device him just being irish i never
would have if you told me a year ago
that would matter to me i wouldn't have
thought of it and it feels so good and
important to be like that character here
and i think that's what drew me in the
first act is i did not expect to have a
marvel experience where i was like this
is suddenly resonating at an 11 where i
wouldn't have ever known that would
matter to me and i think a lot of people
are going to see characters that they're
not going to realize are going to affect
them as much and they're going to go
like that's me and then they're going to
attach themselves to all the
conversations in a bigger way hopefully
it's huge for me i want i want this
movie to succeed because i think marvel
should continue to do different things
and and do things that are more bold and
interesting versus formula yeah you know
like i completely agree with that like i
i like chongqi but you know we talked
about it i had some i had some pretty
big gripes about it through the last
half of the movie i think i just
realized exactly
the the core thing
that is missing for me we did it you
guys i i think i just realized it
because i noticed from our conversation
and then what we talked about with drew
before basically with druid the the the
disparity that we have without spoiling
anything i found the movie kind of
muddied some of his motivation and
intent he explained i'm like no i i got
that
i just didn't really i feel like they
just didn't really quite nail the
execution of it and i think all around
of why i love the shows more than the
movies lately
is because the shows get time to really
explore all those things and if this
great is successful and if you look at
everything we've disagreed on it's
always come down to
yeah i just wanted more of that and i
wanted it to be more fleshed out and i
wanted it to be done but you're just
like yeah be great for like a two person
move for an ensemble two and a half hour
movie you can't and like you have that
in your mindset of the framing around it
being a movie the writer brain in me is
going i kind of want like with druid i'm
like no i get what they're doing i just
wanted them to kind of explore that more
and we just talked about movies tv right
before air separately yes how you watch
more tv than i do yeah it might be
literally a matter of formatting where
my brain is like that's what you get and
i feel like with this kind of movie
especially after dealing with the shows
which i've loved so much the live-action
ones i think that's what i found myself
craving with pretty much everyone here
is i don't think it's like i think for a
movie that they put in the most they
could without it feeling like damn
you're filling this thing up yeah
like like to me i don't agree with uh
like it's convoluted i don't think it's
over convoluted it also doesn't feel
bloated which that's my that's my point
i know some might feel that way but i
think that's not the right word for it i
just found myself going i just wish they
explored this more so i could have felt
more for it
within two minutes of my emotional
connection to using druid as an example
i was able to say what i and you saw it
differently with just like us because
you saw a white man on i was like this
man
looks like me which never happens who am
i
no but like his his arc to me resonated
and i was able to explain like boop boop
and then that opened your perspective
like this so maybe it's a movie where
like a conversation with someone that
didn't emotionally resonate like having
a talk with someone like it might be
just the thing we have to talk about
with people that didn't feel like i felt
i really loved gilgamesh a lot in this
he was the character i probably cared
the most for i loved him a lot he's very
and i like the relationship yeah i did
find myself kind of missing a little
that's the thing is like i think like no
the choice they make with fina i think
is so interesting of what they do with
and they the producers writer someone
came out like like before even the
premiere talking about like the plot
with theena of how she has a thing where
she's like lost a lot of her memory
and uh gilgamesh is take helping take
care of her i found myself going you got
angelina jolie i'm kind of craving a
little bit more here because i like the
idea of doing a more body language
performance with her because angela and
jolie carries so much depth in her eyes
yeah and even in her smile like
sometimes she just smiles at gilgamesh
and i'm like i don't think she you know
wants to sleep with him but man does she
have that like
oh you know what i mean
he just has that smile yeah just like
damn oh man if she smiled at me i just i
just
melted in the ground like a looney tunes
cartoon man
okay so you guys strap him for the four
hour spoiler conversation because i'm
gonna defend every single one of these
examples uh we're gonna see it again i
really honestly like this well the more
i talk about it the more i love it which
is not a common occurrence and i'm
really excited to like break down
examples of why i felt and you might
sound still but there are moments that i
can point to with almost every single
one of your points that i felt yeah and
that's gonna be your your mileage may
vary and i love that i don't want people
to not watch the eternals
yeah look if if i don't like i was
pretty clear about how i felt about
black widows so i'm not going to be like
freaking marvel people
[Music]
you know it's pretty obvious i want to
go to the premieres according to youtube
if you watch our review after like on
the movie reaction we did for vlog widow
i'm
ripping into that and i don't feel like
this is a movie to rip into this is just
one where i'm like i
i wish i had a show and i did i didn't
think i had that thought until right now
where i'm like oh it must be what it is
essentially i kind of wish we had a show
and that's kind of like a common
consensus i'm having with the movies as
of late but i love the theatrical
experience so much i wish we had a show
that played in theaters like i'd like to
go once a week for seasons like i i
think i want my cake and eat it too like
i just want to see these things as big
as like i don't think this would have
worked on tv like the i think it would
have been better oh man that's so
interesting because you could have
really experienced more of the
relationships i don't need to lose the
the theater experience for three hours
more i'd love it that's what you're
saying yeah
i think you would have got of course you
wouldn't have gone in as much of a
living
filmmaking experience
at home yeah of course not so i think
juice works yes i don't really care as
much about that anymore i care more i
feel like i've seen so much by this
point that nothing really dazzles me
anymore dude we got dead you weren't
dazzled by the i was pretty saying you
were dazzled
no
dune there were things about its mood
and atmosphere and the ambiance that it
has that that just sucked my soul in you
know
where eternals didn't have any of that
mood when i'm home i'm not distracted
i never by the way i'm using dune as an
example but i never watched dune
comparing to eternals they're
there's nothing in dune that was like
man eternals could have taken icarus was
uh
should have been ryan gosling
[Laughter]
and blue valentine's michelle
you know this is the roundhouse hasn't
got the stoic thing down i do a great
cyclops grand cause me good cyclops i'd
like that stoic success right no you
can't hide his eyes what's wrong with
you baby goose why would you do wrong
why would you do with this
that's like
saying hey will smith you want to be an
after earth and not have charisma
robbing
i was so impressed with the rest he has
so many things he's got more than just
eyes yeah richard madden you liked him a
lot i did because he was on my four and
chris was one of the four i was i was
fully i felt like he was comfortable
with icarus in a way that i didn't
expect from not knowing a lot of his
work he'd be in a character of that like
icarus is such an important eternal yeah
and he really walked that walk and i
felt like he was a being of timelessness
i think he did a great job none of my
issues fall performance fall down on
performance i'm like no i think everyone
does a great job it's just what
something is so dialogue but something
is so dialogue heavy it's hard for me to
be like but the tone and the mood and
the visuals were enough right for me i
i'm more caught up in the the actual
scene work yeah you know and that was
enough for me and how the seam work
really made me feel i'm really curious
if the second time you get the emotional
resonance and like it changes your whole
experience because i love debate like
like 12 angry men phenomenal yeah like i
love a good debate movie and i didn't
until recently so that's why i don't
think it'll do well i love david fincher
films for for that purpose i love loki
for that you know like i love debate i i
really fully
imagine that on rewatch it'll i'll like
it more um
i think the deviants are gonna see the
uh there's a spoiler thing about the
deviance that bugs me so
there's one thing about the plot that
i'll say about that um that i want to
touch on there's there is a thing about
the deviants that they don't do
that i feel like a show would have at
least addressed i'll tell you right now
just on my own personal level
what why went to the eternal entire
conversation
but it doesn't feel like a conflict oh i
totally did it for me they barely talked
about it oh man i thought that was i was
like that's a room for a real conflict
the last fight they like tried talking
good they shoved it in at the very end
so they couldn't explore it reviews
would be a blast it's gonna be a whole
mess
kevin foggy's watching me talking with
you and john anyway what do you think of
a car i thought she was incredible i i
love that we've got a character that has
a mental uh health issue a character
that represents a community that is
differently abled i think we have a
character that represents uh a different
sexuality than most people in the
midwest might see we've got a character
that represents uh kind of like a
zealousy that is really inherent to
humanity like it represents way more
people than i think even we look at it
objectively yeah i don't know totally i
think objectively speaking i think
that's one thing that the movie i love
that they set out to do that was take
these these cosmic beans and how do we
make them relatable yeah and how do
whoever does it
how do we make them more grounded to
keep them on earth and mainly watch them
hang out and i love that and i really
liked dazed and eternals what do you
think of sprite she worked for me
because the actress was able to do a lot
with a little bit of time the character
in the comic books was really
interesting because she's got a lot of
time to discuss the things she survived
and in this she doesn't because there's
so much going on but i did buy the
things that made her sprite i did buy
the the struggle with being young
forever i bought that but there's a lot
more in the comics also i just put this
together this is my epiphany mid review
i might have a different experience of
being emotionally resonating with them
because i was exposed to them before
maybe i felt no i think a lot of most
people don't know the eternals on the
most people i talk to uh feel for this
movie okay yeah because i was like i
just realized like i felt this about i
mean i don't have a backstory for sprite
that most people wouldn't have i'm not
gonna say it's not a factor right like
when you see because you your experience
you walk away from you go it has been
improved upon so i feel more for it
because i never felt for druid and now i
do well for me this is my introduction
right i only know facts about them prior
to watching because i had to research
crap i think sprite you know like i i
saw some mixed opinions about her when
talking with some people after the
screening i think she actually did an
excellent job oh i totally and yes we
did do an interview with her and i'm not
going to just hate when people said like
we did an interview with her but it's
i'm not saying because we interviewed i
actually think she did an excellent job
to hire a child actress who has to be
not seen as a child when hanging out
with these veteran actors where everyone
is the same age i was never like
they got a kid for this
like i just bought her as a person i
just bought her as one of them i just
bought her as equal of age i never
watched her in the light of i'm watching
a child actor try to keep up with the
yeah that's really better actors and i
think that's a major testament to her
performance i agree it's all [ __ ]
i'm just saying that because interview
no that's just a fact i think kit
harrington the brief amount of time he's
in this movie
i think he has great screen presence
he's really funny and amusing
post-credits scene's been room for a lot
of people no we won't touch on it oh
that sucks i oh you like were smart
person from variety i blocked variety
dude that person from variety flat out
right after the premiere just says what
happened i heard and i blocked them
pre-emptive and i blocked all the
differences you heard he spoiled me you
know but you know what yeah oh that's
what he spoiled yeah he swallowed it the
whole i was like i don't believe this i
also i had someone tweet it at me but i
i i i had left my [ __ ] alone and then i
came back after the movie and then i did
my video about like you know integrity i
do think that variety there should be
repercussions it's a great post-credits
scene yeah if you already read what
happened
it worked so much better within context
if you were kind of cynical towards oh
you heard yeah yeah i would be weird
yeah honestly if i heard i might be like
what really
yeah but watching it in the uh in the
actual movie was like oh that's a good
scene and there's two there's two uh
that if i think that last one was very
predictable like i think like a year ago
everyone sure much semi follows the
turtles was like i think this is going
to be the post credits it's an important
one but there's a button flare to it
that i will say that is not predictable
agreed that's that's what i'll leave
that at and it's dope it's dope both
post credit scenes are like usually in
marvel there's a post-credits scene
that's like a stinger tied to the film
and then a world building one both of
these are giant world building ones and
as different as it is i don't think it's
completely devoid of
both things about mcu that you might not
like about some movies and also
typical mcu things that you do like
about
there are qualities of both some are
like well that's
well that's fortunate
there's a couple of moments you're like
oh yeah yeah there are structural things
that i'm like structurally it's more
about the scenes they place into the
structure that make it more unique okay
but i think structurally it's pretty
similar i didn't feel like it was a
three-act structure at all because of
the ticking clock thing happening later
i felt like there was a night i felt
like it was like a five act film instead
of three all right so yeah maybe it is
more the fact that we're having this
conversation to this extent usually
about 20 minutes because we yeah on our
time we won't clock into this has been
over an hour but the fact that we are
having a conversation to this extent
about it and it's not talking about like
this is stupid
it's perhaps perhaps it is more artistic
than i gave a credit for thank you um
yeah
you know we gotta as the representative
of this film i appreciate your time
i don't know if you will dude it's a
daunting experience i think i think it's
going to be really interesting to see
the people what people get out of this i
don't know that people will resonate
like i did you know what's so weird to
me about me saying i'm going to be the
minority and you are not the first
person to tell me like i don't think you
will what's weird to me is i don't think
this is a last jedi situation oh no
that's not even normal though that was
interesting that was unhealthy i don't
think general fans are uh getting enough
credit for being able to appreciate a
movie like this i don't think general
fans will want to have these
conversations that are necessary to
appreciate it you think people might
just walk out and go it's kind of boring
yeah that's my fear and i hope i'm wrong
please be wrong every time i'm wrong and
humanity is better than i think i'm
happy that's why i like this movie i
mean i saw a couple of people who did
not say this publicly um who thought it
was a little pretentious which i
disagree with patently and i think it
does a great job normalizing things that
could be pretentious as much as i craved
more and wanted it to be better in in
these other areas like for my personal
taste i never would have applied the
word pretentious to it not neither i
i've seen something i'm also [ __ ]
i love being alex the fact that i'm
dissecting a movie that i could have
never
to this degree it makes me pretentious
i'm just saying we comment on art for a
little bit here we are like we're as
pretentious as it gets and i'm going i
don't think it's protected
yeah no i didn't i personally didn't
find it pretentious but i can't fault
someone for finding it that way yeah i
mean it's everybody's own experience
like what we've been saying i would
still just for the ambition
concept and just filmmaking alone
i would still give this like a three to
three and a half somewhere there out of
five
just for that fact alone just
emotionally i was like a 1.5 to two yeah
so if the film was a five and you feel
one point five three three i'm just like
i love the theme of choice with here and
the actual choice on the filmmaking and
all around from what they wanted to do
to like script-wise to the actual
physical filmmaking elevates what i
would say and that's why i still want
people to watch this
i give it a four and a half uh i've only
ever given intentions i am the monster
who i am i've only ever and in context
i've only ever given 16 films five stars
and only one of those in mcu films this
is four and a half stars for me because
it succeeds at its very lofty ambitions
of which there are many it is a movie
about uh very brilliantly dense concepts
to have discussions like this about
while never being boring or pretentious
and it also elevates the entire
filmmaking and comic book alike like it
elevates comic books it elevates movies
it allows you to make a 200 million
dollar indie film and it does that while
having a conversation that elevates one
of my favorite franchises ever it is a
very clean a for me and it does things
that i didn't think were possible so it
gets that extra half so far it's for so
long i hope people will not be turned
off by looking at the length of it do
you mean like
[Laughter]
get turned off by the runtime when they
see it because i i don't know i i'm
happy we have this conversation and
in fairness you went up a half point uh
you were at three last night and you're
out of three and a half yeah
definitely the fact that we are having
this conversation to like this
and not about
the marvel stuff a typical review of
just like let's go let's make a bullet
point in this cinematography we didn't
talk we barely talked directing because
you guys just need to know that's great
right that's all good
don't worry about that and i think we're
going to get you after our our spoiler
conversation at like 375. i think we're
going to go up a little bit more i think
you're gonna be locked i've been
watching three seven five i'm gonna
watch it again before we do our spoiler
talk yeah and i'll be honest i love it i
think we'll get them there and uh i
would love to know what you guys think
as well in the comments i i read these
comments like a monster i'm an idiot i
read youtube comments who do i think i
am a fool i try to be as clear-cut as
possible and people still will go greg
just did he assume this bridges won't
say it's boring or something marvel [ __ ]
i just can't say it i just i don't think
it's i don't think it's boring but i
also don't find it particularly exciting
it should sound like i'm sorry i have a
great emotion about it what do you know
thank you guys for being here hopefully
some people watch this
and uh see you guys soon
[Music]
you